this is a folded example of the
miura-ori pattern it is famous not just
an origami but in engineering as well
and it is useful because it is
contracting and expanding it is an
example of a negative Poisson ratio
material so there has been some interest
in using this as a kind of meta material
for which you can tune is properties in
particular its compressibility
properties so the pure we are already
compresses like so but you can introduce
defects I've introduced a defect here
this corner and the area of the defect
the paper is distorted a bit and it
changes the compressibility properties
of this pattern as a material so what
happens if you introduce a number of
these defects what happens when you when
you flood this thing with the effects
and will it still hold up in the same
way so my research is centered on
quantifying the effect of defects how
neighboring defects interact with each
other and at what point do you lose all
long-range order in this material so in
in order to do that I related or got me
to an area of physics named statistical
mechanics and I consider each of the
defect as an atom that ninka that can
interact with its neighbors and with
sufficient number of atoms interacting
you can show that the me Rory has a
phase transition a point at which all of
the long-range order in the material
vanishes